and I'll just Expendable Commodities
they could just
isn't it isn't it crazy how men built
the world for us and then we [__] on
them as a thank you that's what I'm
saying it is crazy I think I I find it
incredibly incredibly sad incredibly sad
because we're supposed to be coming
together as as as people who who should
love each other and and spread Joy
rather than literally it's hate hate and
anger all the time and I see all these
people and I'm just like
why do you like all this drama by the
way why do you want to come home your
man's tired and then you're gonna I
don't know yell at them because oh I'm
tired and he put his foot up on the
table you know something really silly
and why can't you just have an adult
conversation and respect the fact that
hey he's tired too and yes okay we maybe
there are things that need ironing out
but why don't we have an adult
conversation why do you have to raise
your voice and be disrespectful to each
other yeah um did you see did you guys
see the video it was a tick tock video
and it went pretty viral of this uh
military wife and
um she were a [__] another husband
trying to uh get him to do the laundry
and this is while he was like off for
like I don't know I don't know how it
works in the US but it's like the
rougher two the two weeks on for a
certain period of time but it was off
and
um she were like complaining about him
doing the laundry well you know when
he's on duty he's risking his life even
in training you know because training
deaths happen a lot so like it's just
mad to me that that's even like
[Music]
that guy deserves so much better yeah
can I just point out what the problem is
it's not even the fact that she did it
it's the fact that it's even public
um men deserve response no no no no no
I'm not saying that that's not even the
worst bit is what I'm saying the fact
that she made it public yeah she's
literally publicly humiliating this poor
man I'm sorry if you have a problem be
an adult talk to each other as adults
you trying to air your dirty laundry
literally to other people so if you
girls do this all the time I see it and
it's I hate it they they will they will
go to their friends and hang out
together and then all of a sudden
they're gonna say oh my God what's the
problem with the man they like can't
they just like put like their trousers
like can I just put it in the basket I
even got a really nice basket it's like
there I put it in the spot where he
drops it and and he just wouldn't do it
I don't get it like what's wrong with
him and I'm just like why are you doing
this to him
um so question let's go around what are
your personal standards yeah so what
would you expect from a woman and what
would you guys expect from a man like
minimum requirements to date them well
I'd say right now I can't expect much
um but I am you know in the process as I
said I'm young and uh I do plan on you
know making six figures eventually I got
the six foot down unlock and I think I'm
pretty cute So eventually I'll have the
standards set in place but right now I'm
focus on on my career but I do have you
know anticipations for my standards
which is um you know submission like
um and
just
Peace of Mind someone who can offer me
peace of mind you know someone that's
not always in my life you did this wrong
I don't want that you know like if I'm
if I'm willing to provide right um and
be the breadwinner then
um if she wants to work fine but
obviously the the common thing is that
you prefer she stays home yes but
yeah she does want to work right
everyone says you need a you need the
masculine trait to work right
um especially in a career so
but like when she gets home
she drops that masculinity at the door
because I'm not I'm not competing in my
own household I gotta compete with other
men out in the world to look at me six
foot tattoos beard and then they just
like assume I'm top dog and then
competition time I don't know if that's
more of a you thing so like because I'm
a you
but uh yeah it's certainly what I'm
experiencing right now so I definitely
do not want to have that in the
household that I'm paying for
yeah I agree I think for me my woman
must offer peace man because I know how
much I work I know how when I come home
I want her that my household to be my my
safe space to be you know peaceful and
relaxed and also I think the most number
one thing is she's gotta be she's gotta
be feminine she has to be able to submit
um she has to be family orientated
because I don't have kids yet but that's
that's the main goal I want to have kids
I want her to be a family based person
um preaching yeah that's it is that how
your girl is now yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah she's reach back as
well
we're working on it so don't put me
under pressure
good so um I do want
in my terms I do want a a man who
respects me I want a masculine man so
exactly what you guys are saying a man
who has great achievements he has a path
he's ready to work on himself to make
himself better and he also respects me
and someone that I will feel proud of
and I would want to give him the love
and support as you said as a woman and
be his his number one fan I want to be
his home I want to be the person that he
can come to me where everyone else he'll
be a bit on guard and he will feel
comfortable to just drop it a little bit
because I am his home so what what does
he have to have because you're kind of
describing what you want to be for him
but the question was like what what does
he have to be in order to get that so
for me it's rather than the view of a
height requirement no no he could be
short at five foot I dated a man that
was shorter than me before for two years
okay so I'm I'm not I will say this I'm
not very normal but
for me I have learned the value of the
true value of a person isn't their
exterior it's it's their insides it's
their personalities it's whether they
fit me so for example one of the things
because I did a personality test of
Jordan Peterson's okay and one of the
things he looks at is agreeableness and
one of my criteria I want for my man is
I want him to be less agreeable than me
why because I am quite agreeable and I'm
always worrying that maybe I might step
on someone's toes but someone who's less
agreeable is not going to be as easily
uh you know like offended so I like that
I don't have to feel you know like can I
tell you are you gonna get offended so
for example so okay this is like kind of
broad so I just I want to be a little
bit more specific so you want someone
disagreeable what else
so what's some more disagreeable does he
have respectful income income required I
would like him to be
um from a skill set knowledge income
level equal to me okay which is roughly
well I um I earn around 3 000 a month so
maybe something like that okay
um is there anything else that you want
roughly like at your income or more
would you ever submit to a guy that
makes less than you
yes because it's not about the now
people are changing no no he's staying
at that it's not build a man so he's no
no no it's not I'm not saying that I'm
trying to build him but this is the
thing like just because a man may not be
as good now doesn't mean he isn't later
it's about realizing no but I'm saying
like a lot of times like girls we try to
build a man like we go to build a bear
but but guys like like I don't know what
I'm saying I'm saying like when you said
it's not about the now it's about the
later that's implying that you're you
would want him to his income to increase
but I'm saying like most guys kind of
are where they're at especially like you
said you're 34. so if a guy's 35 like 35
like I'd imagine you want roughly your
age or older so so maybe for me that's
the thing like so for me I
honestly all I'm gonna say is I've
realized that the physical shell of
things
they're not as important as peace and
the the person that's inside does that
come of age though did you realize that
100 well this is and this is the thing
like this is something I've learned this
is something that I internalized I had
to go I was single for I'm been single
still single for a long time because
guess what I needed to work on myself
like if I'm broken and I'm not in the
right frame of mind I'm gonna end up
damaging another person I don't want
that if I'm not ready then I'm gonna
work on myself and to be honest like yes
I'll be it's difficult to give you a
figure but the people with the six
figures who are getting all these girls
and driving Lambos I don't want them
either is is monogamy a requirement for
you for me yes okay do you feel like
that's a fair deal for a guy
um because he's not getting you for your
best years
that depends on what the man wants so
I'm saying like long term like I'm and
this is going for like me too none of us
are virgins anymore so I think like men
value Purity and youth right and they're
not getting that anymore so do you think
it's a fair deal for men when they're
not getting that to be monogamous to us
to comprise on their mating strategy
when we don't fulfill theirs because
we're not virgins anymore because I feel
like when you talk about something and
saying that that's the only reason you
have value I think that's wrong because
I think it's that it's not I'm not
saying that's the only reason you have
value I'm talking about your value in
the dating market and like like results
are harsh the world's harsh and like the
truth is modern women are less pure than
they've ever been and we're older than
we've ever been so I'm asking do you
think that's a fair deal for men when
they have to be more and more less
if a man is going to look at me and say
that the only value I come I can bring
to the table is because of my no I
didn't say the only value so I'm not
saying that's the only value like you
seem like a smart girl I know you have
more than just that but I'm saying in
the dating market like this is what it
starts with and it's harsh but it's
reality
so yeah just um but you're saying we're
going with age and we're going with well
it's like men men value Purity and youth
so they like young virgins that's the
that's the ideal just like our ideal is
like rich men right but I'm saying now
in today's day and age like women have
higher standards than ever but bring
less to the table than ever we're older
we've slept with more people and we have
less loyalty because we're the ones
leaving them
yeah so I'm saying do you think that's a
fair deal for men
I think it generally depends on the
person I'm sorry I can't answer that
question okay go ahead what are your
requirements for a guy uh that he's
aware of the the traditional gender
roles okay and I expect that and he
expects that from me and reciprocity and
I think respect his earned I can't I
don't expect him just to respect me just
like that because I'm a woman I think he
needs to get to know me and um the
relationship has to be reciprocal and I
I'm 28 and I don't
I actually want him to be polygenous
really yeah
they're gonna fall in love with you in
the church
the reason why and um I could speak so
much about it they're calling you an
Indian Queen right now